hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
just look at this TV alright so we saw a
lot of pretty cool TVs at CES like we do
every year but a lot of the coolest ones
never really go on sale they're more
like showcases but this this one is real
this is the LG 4k OLED W in the flesh
and the W stands for wallpaper and
that's a pretty footing name for a TV
like this because it's so thin it
literally looks like a cutout like a
wallpaper on a 65 inch section of the
wall so for the record the panel is
officially 3.8 millimeters thick total
including the wall mount if you must
know there's actually no way to keep
this TV upright there's no stand that it
comes with you have to wall mount it if
you're getting it so the OLED module is
basically a 65 inch sheet of pixels that
sort of hooks on to the tiny wall mount
at the top like a picture frame and that
actually uses magnets throughout the
middle and the bottom of the frame to
stay flush with the wall it's tight so
that makes it thinner on the wall than a
bunch of household objects which you
would ordinarily consider thin I mean
the fact that this whole panel is about
the same thickness as two SD cards
should give you a pretty good idea how
nuts it is maybe take a key out your
pocket and hold it up to the wall like
that is how thin the entire TV is and
yeah that also makes this TV that LG
makes thinner than the thinnest phone
they make how about that and then the
OLED itself is an excellent quality
panel as it should be for the price it
gets up to a thousand nits which is
extremely bright
blacks are pitch black since it's an
OLED it hits 99% of DCI color space
supports Dolby vision HDR 10h LG and
Technicolor's HDR I mean it'll pretty
much cover any format and of course it's
a 4k panel so details and contrast and
sharpness are incredible up close as
close as you would ever get to a TV this
big but where did all the guts go so
where are all the rest of the components
to this TV the ports the speakers etc
it's actually all in the soundbar we
an equally important part of this setup
as the OLED so everything connects to
the TV through this one flat cable and
you can see it coming out the bottom and
it looks a little bit weird at first but
I kind of dig this system it's a really
really sturdy cable doesn't flex very
much but it comes right out the bottom
of the TV and plugs into the sound bar
and I have mine using the extension
since it's more than 2 feet from the TV
to the bar I think ideally for maximum
visual flotation you're gonna want to go
into the wall with the cable so you
don't have to see it at all but then you
need some professional help and you have
to get it properly shielded for fire
code etc I think some double-sided tape
for me should do pretty much fine to
make it not a big deal now the cable
really is not that noticeable once
they're looking at the TV trust me but
this sound bar this thing is actually
really good it sounds great it gets
really loud without much distortion it
has a bunch of speakers frontward facing
sideways straight up and that makes it
pretty good at throwing sound off the
walls and creating a pretty convincing
surround sound effect and check out the
sleek little animation it does when
turning on and off I I can't even be
sure if that has any real functionality
outside of looking cool but I like it
anyway and all of the i/o is of course
in the sandbar as well so you plug in
your sound bar into the wall and if you
have anything HDMI there's 4 HDMI ports
a couple USB an ethernet etc and then
all of that gets fed through to the TV
along with power through that ribbon
cable so that's what allows the TV to be
so thin because it's literally just the
OLED panel and some shielding and a few
magnets and that's it as far as what's
up on your wall the dopest of your setup
with this TV will depend pretty much on
how well you can hide this cable so yeah
you can color me impressed
I'm glad to even have it in the studio
now thanks to LG and even after using it
for a couple days sometimes you still
find herself wondering like why did it
have to get so thin like what's the
difference between a TV that's one inch
thick and this panel that's a tenth of
an inch thick but then you use it and
you remember why it's the thinness
combined with these really thin bezels
that create a super immersive viewing
and gaming experience I can't even
imagine how insane the 77 inch version
of looks probably just looks like a
straight-up projection which
is crazy so okay the bottom line for
this is most people aren't ever really
gonna buy this I mean uh it's $8,000 if
you want to that's on you bro I get it
but for most people this is more of just
a showcase of what the bleeding edge of
Texas whole concept is in new of having
a super thin TV and then putting most of
the i/o and the electronics down at the
bottom we've seen that before even LG
and Samsung have done that in the
bottoms of their TVs before put the
speaker's the HDMI ports all of it in
the bottom even though the thinnest part
of the TV is really thin but this this
is taking it to the next level that's
why it's dope tech it's just seeing
what's possible with taking as much away
from it as possible
and when you do this you end up with
this super immersive experience where
you don't even really focus on the fact
that it's a TV anymore it just looks
like someone copied and pasted an image
onto a wall and you're just looking at
the image it's really cool so I can
leave a link in the description to this
if you really want to check it out but
really most of the links I'll leave or
the videos I was watching on the TV and
the stuff on the TV if you want to check
those things out but uh that's pretty
much it that's the wallpaper TV thank
you for watching talk to you guys the
next one peace
[Music]